人和人最大的差距就是认知
认知并不能直接帮你转钱
但是认知能决定你转多少钱
为什么我会穷吗
其实是和认知有关的
刚才整号直播本来讲今天晚上给大家打电影一整套认知系统框架结果
现在之前的一半
我简单的通过一个视频
帮大家打一个简单的认知框架系统
然后一些关键的知识
什么许愿方向是什么
这个还是很重要
所以老习惯
说一件事情就是讲干什么是什么
但是我把
最简直的框架搞的
认知可以分三部分
第一部分就是
你的事业
你能看到什么
你有些东西都看着看不到
那更做不到了
第二个部分是什么的就是你做什么
你做什么就是你的绝错
选择大人努力吗
怎么选择呀怎么做决策呀
对吧
第三个部分是怎么做
就方法论
首先我们说第一个部分
就是事业
你能看到什么
其实是合适业官有关
我也在说就是我们很多
我们都被出去看过这个世界
我们的世界观都是由身边的人或者数本告诉我们
然后有意思是告诉我们这些
人他们自己好像
也没出去看到过什么世界对吧
那你会发现我们用这套世界观去理解世界
其实是问题的
很小很小的例子
比如说
第一个主播是一万
我们大家都知道钱很重要
都知道钱很重要
但是我们不会争钱
也没人教我呢
我们也不去学院
当然有人跟你讲
赚钱的事
你会觉得很楼
然后你还赚不了钱
你们觉得你不觉得这个世界观有问题吗
所以各位好好想象你为什么赚不了钱
就是你对钱的理解是错的
所以给大家一个建议讲
花点时间好好要解一下
钱的本质是什么
比如说多点建议学
多多历史
钱是本质是什么东西
钱是怎么来的
了解一下
这个交易是怎么来的
欧德马里的钱是什么来的
比如说像马斯克
阿伯像那个
盲格呀
像巴巴斯克呀
总欧德马里的钱是什么来的
了解一下
你欧马里的钱是什么来的
比如说像
这个马斯克呀
像哥哥用磨
对吧
这些人的钱
到底是什么来的
就是钱是不合持续
你这个东西的意义了以后
然后你才能赚到钱
不是说
我觉得钱的东西要
但是我还不好意思提钱
我就钱很安赞
一提钱你说很楼
对吧
你是这么着急的
而且我明確报道一下
有些东西如果你听才不对
那么
关于钱都是能说一讲
如果你发现你都你没有你想我的东西
那
我觉得你在说不对之前
好好想想是不是我的世界关除了问题
换掉了至少我的意义的世界和真实世界
是不一样的
我其实我的世界问和真实世界是不一样的
我觉得你好好体会有时候说这个话
而不是看到不一当一眼去觉得
人家那个世界关有问题
所以
这是
第一个事情就是我们的事业
从这个地方给了分享一个关于
是一关可以帮你真的小钱的问题吧
九例子比如说你从
北战国这种医线城市
你带过今年了
带过今年了对吧
你也不能取得抓城市
但是你在这个医线网的也城市带过今年了
在这个生活我了你真的生活了对吧
现在你回到无留线城市
你一定能找到一些政策的方法
我说这个政策方法不是说你
逼你怎么样
而是拼无留线城市你身边的那些
以前的朋友们
你政策的方法
和脑子要比他们灵活躲
所以你能力一些吧
如果你能力一些这个道理的话那就很简单了
对吧
就是吃点茶,地鱼茶,清洗茶,认知上
这就是吃点的方法
吃点关,这是地鱼茶事情
走出去看看
看你的事业
让我们自己能看到更多的东西
而不是把自己疯独在原头的
是这里
第二件事情就是怎么做绝策
怎么绝做绝策的方法其实
是很重要的
举了例子吧比如说
别的还举了例子,几个几个几个几件事情啊
比如说
通俗举了例子比如说
做绝策的方法是什么
有哪些做绝的方法
我怎么知道我做的这个绝策是对的还是错的
你有没有绝对的
说绝策例子比如说地鱼,高兴怎么来
就他们说完呀,我们去选哪个设面考虑
设面好像是连下转钱,设面好像是不转钱的为什么
设面好像也搭都设面都去了人多了
你是可不期待的,我几个小例子吧
说好玩笑啊
好多人现在听说AI转钱
跟一些人去包的AI后,让你指望的中间
我们几个小问题
比如说一个大老公
买了你几万的,就卖了几万是
白哀克
就说这些中间
然后你花了钱去的上了AI后
你就觉得能中间,你不觉得这个时常搞笑吗
花钱就上,这么多人还都弄上
你得这个能装钱吗
你这怎么想了呢
对了
所以各位
高兴能不能中间,取学欺缺信
欺缺信,我跟有例子
论欺股互是很辛苦
这么重要,价值高高高
故事
是赚不到什么钱的
为什么,原因很简单
细学
我带给你取一个
可以转钱的想法,几个例子
顶家的
儿科压益
儿童压益
你说这个东西,他是技术性的问题吗
压益吗,就好多,但是我告诉你
好的儿童压益
他这个政策,为什么,因为第一次是刚许
孩子压益回掉,谁家还了压不掉
没压了,是吧,还了压益回掉
但是,但是这个问题都不取得压益,压益的技术的居于什么
就你要去
这孩子也压的问题的时候
孩子情绪应该怎么安途
这个普通人能不能做到,我告诉你,你真的花时间,你真的做
对不对,他说真的,他真的取得一致什么
你得个高等院校去逼业的吗,好像不需要了
但这个东西,他就是新学兴的
刚去,但是你想做好,你需要花钱的一花时间
这就是新学兴,记得高兴取决于
新学兴
不几决于什么,至少什么,学历压,不是的
学历去,因为上个好说,学历什么,就是
就是进程的时候,那么多人,进程的过程中,你能灾在那个新学的底
都会能力的吗
不是你学历高,你觉得中间
是因为你的进程中形象,他肯定在那个点上,新学
没选队,没选队只要不行的
第二个事情就是,比如说你创业做产品,我告诉你,学历历什么
学历他的规模和复理性
今天我调调的过程中,说我以前做资讯
资讯不是个好之业,我们有个大错误在下面留言说
我资讯是个很好之业,你不懂我,不懂我,我做了好的年资讯,我不懂
我给你俩讲,为什么资讯他不是个好之业
因为他是一段一的,而你在世界之前是不是有钱,一条画板
本来是很容易刻荡画的,但是我差的很 Ngoten Those things
但是你会发现现在我就说的你好,究竟这件事情
规模
我才能用400万钱慢慢的,能吃了500万钱
能够切了300万钱
是不是可以复理的
看不到天或者有条画板
最后那里面就做下面的创意,要选择什么规模党
同时可复理的什么就随着时间的程度
越做越越越好
这个是创业做产品应该做的事情
投资是什么
投资考的是改率和基礎
你一定要理解改率
投资是改率啊
这个你要明白
所以问题是什么就是你在亏的时候要尽可能少亏少
亏无数字的无所谓
这个钱很少亏的时候少少的
但是转的时候高高的
投资考的是这个
他不是说你每次都判断到对
那怎么去解决气率性
就好多人之所以亏的原因什么是没气率无组是无气率
其他也不一样
好吧
所以各位你看
这就是做角色的风
做角色的方法很多
就比如说我再给大家久了一次
我们很多时候只伤都差不太多的
你们一定看到很多人就是批我聪明的
批我智慧的对不对
但是我告诉你我特别智慧的一件事什么
是我知道我不做什么
你很聪明你做了好多事
我我能扮演但是我智慧呀
我智慧呀
我知道什么能力不做
我把我的经历做的最重要的事情
这其实就是差别这些选择
什么不做这个很重要的
对吧就觉得错嘛就掉了
这三个部分是什么呢就是什么做
有方法问问你答应是做什么是有方法问的
我给大家几个小例子啊比如说
做事这个事情其实它是个方法的呢
拿我来说
我可以在48小时只能去见证一个事
什么时候我知不错是方法的
我知我快速创意的方法的
我知我快速是错的方法的
几个很小的这一座啊就是你们很运做事
害怕失败连那个卖都卖不出去的
我们好多人拍个视频干个啥呀
对过人朋友啊清晰呀
你们去看完云美红的当年怎么创意到刺体发传单单的
第一天一刚开始成为怎么创意到刺体在那北京南战发传单单的
在你们看来觉得好多人啊
这是有方法问的
比如说我去现象一个比如说卖一个商品做个商品
同样卖活我我的成功率更高的为什么呢我给你一个例子啊
我卖什么东西呢
我回去店上平台去找那个两三分之差平
差平不能选1分0分了那种不行
那是情绪特别大的
选两分3分但是他情绪不是考不是发现情绪的
他是很认真的很理晶的
我说过平家的
哇
这个是真正的用
用户这么早
你才知道用户的痛点和需求什么
然后第二件事情马上去想
这个问题背后的多有什么
我能不能用一个很简单的免费的东西就快速地去
不是我真的去找工厂去做的
千万不要一上一找工厂做
而是怎么能给的提供一个
提倡提倡品让它能解决这个问题
所以我要去想一个很简单的方法
提倡品什么叫提倡品
我们
几个很小的一个字啊
有说
我有些人喜欢喝那个名字啊
你可能有产品把名字开始做好
你可以怎么可以先切啊
是不是
提倡品他能解决用户的问题
你给
很多的事情提供一个提倡品的这个
你不一定要钱
但是得对方
然后的话呢看对方的法康
对方是不是感谢啊是不是愿意
发一些
这个小钱一些
红包给你对吧
然后你在做的很多这种事情
你比如说包括本来快速的那些人
写就是人家抱怨的吗
直接发怨的
你不是不能要钱去的
你怎么让人家不反感
让人愿意试用你的方案
刚开始可以免费可以试用的
那他愿没有跟你反归的
愿没有跟你多交流呢
愿没有跟你一些红包呢
对吧头的时间也是成本的
你通过这个牺牲就可以判断
是不是有用户的
如果有用户这个事是可以玩走
如果没有用户不要紧
快速的
4850张马上下一个4850再去说下一个
所以我们是有方法的怎么能够快速的
怎么能够低重的事情
然后怎么能够快到市场怎么能按到底该怎么写
对吧怎么快速的做一个小产品
这些东西都是方法人
所以你看我们在做事的时候一个人只是跟看到一个机会
然后快速做一个方法就成结的
没有那么多时间去纠结的对吧
所以各位好好体会一下就是
做你的认知
几个部分第一个部分就是
怎么能
或者你的事业
怎么开货你的事业万
你需要看数据还是要走回去还是接触外面的世界
对吧
这个就是
世界观的问题
第二件事情怎么做就错
有哪些现场的思维模型可以帮我做就错
比如说什么思考快一慢啊
对吧
比如说思维模型啊
查理盟的多微思维模型啊
这都是在那个里面那些思维模型可以帮我做就错
我怎么发现
我的这个思维模型
和不合适
包括怎么选择高兴啊怎么就做产品到关键什么
投资要干什么怎么就做绝对的方法
算是眼睛的
第三个部分就是
怎么去做
怎么去做怎么就有方法认的
对
创业就不可怕
不可怕的
就很认的理解什么就是创业就是创业不创业就
创业就是创业就是创业就是创业就是创业就是创业就是
但是因为你没有法法论的创业这么长时间是有法法论的
怎么用法法论快乐的事情
好归
看到什么我的事业我的事业关
第二个怎么做绝错
我选择做什么
第三个我怎么做
弄法论